on va accueillir tout de suite hapsatou
puisqu'on va revenir sur cette affaire
minute après minute
minute par minute avec ce qui s'est
passé avec eric zemmour absatou je suis
très heureux de l'avoir ce soir à tous
ces thèmes populistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça jouait traversier déjà de venir nous
voir et à sa touche voudrais dire à vous
démarrez toute cette histoire je devrais
dire nous aussi on a eu un petit un
petit différend à l'époque et parce que
j'ai fait une vanne sur ton compagnon et
tu avais répondu sur twitter de sang
s'était parlé tous les deux et j'avais
adoré le fait que tu défendes tonton
notre compagnon et j'avais dit et depuis
on est resté assez proches tous les deux
et tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup et
j'aime bien parce que tu es voilà tué à
suez vrai tu es cash et tu ne ment pas
c'est pour ça que je t'aime beaucoup
sont encore par les ir et voilà je suis
très heureux que tu sois là et je sais
c'est pas des faits c'est pas du mytho
c'est pas pour faire du buzz
hapsatou comme je dis allez un petit peu
comme ici elle est vraie elle est
vivante elle dit les choses et quand
elle devient un truc elle le vit à fond
alors je vois revenir d'abord sur la
sphère après vous donnerez votre avis et
matthieu delormeau
parce que pour l'instant m'agace merci
d'être là cette affaire donc s'est
déroulée en plusieurs actes alors 17h02
hapsatou c'était dimanche publie un
mystérieux tweet dans lequel elle
explique avoir été très marquée par une
séquence qui sera diffusé plus tard dans
la soirée sur ces apps à toucy donc ce
soir les terriens le moment le plus
douloureux que j'ai eu à vivre en télé
face à un zemmour hargneux insultant et
agressif envers moi toujours très
affecté d'ailleurs donc après le
tournage on va le dire les terrains du
dimanche sont le jeudi je dis donc après
le tournage vous allez passer trois
jours très difficiles
hapsatou et vous avez invité les
téléspectateurs à regarder cette
émission pour voir ce que vous aviez
vécu ce qu'avait été donc garder au
montage de l'émission les terriens du
dimanche mais pendant trois jours je
sais que ça a été assez dure pour vous
et que vous avez cogiter sur ce qui
s'était passé
voilà ensuite 19h16 la fameuse séquence
est ensuite diffusés dont casino
19h16 sur ces 8 on voit eric zemmour
dérapé sur le plateau des terriens tout
le monde a vu cette image mais souvenez
vous de ces propos regarder home
allemand chez moi on doit donner des
prénoms dans ce qu'on appelle le
calendrier c'est à dire les incrétines
novembre
la fête moi votre mairie ah bon ma mère
a eu tort à la lutte en voudriez donc je
m'appelle comment corinne ça nous irait
très bien trouvé alors là amsatou là
vous êtes sur le plateau je sens que
tout rigole un peu que ça et là vous
vous dites quoi vous en faites pas je
rigole mais pas du tout à ce jeu c'est
non mais ça ils vont un peu vos
camarades rigoler parce que c'est comme
si on a pu faire des erreurs on dirait
que tout ça mais on est dans le show on
rigole on voit pas tout de suite que le
truc grave qui se passe sur le plateau
mais c'est surtout que c'est parce ça
qu'il se passe juste le nerf est comme
ça oui voilà c'est effectivement monté
comme ça mais la séquence elle dure bien
plus longtemps ou effectivement eric
zemmour m'humilie m'insulte alors s'en
prend à mes parents continuent exacte et
ricane il m'a dit que mon prénom était
une insulte à la france que mes parents
avaient eu tort que mes parents
devraient avoir honte que je devrais
avoir honte voilà il a été touché sur le
plateau tout ça sur le plateau ça était
insoutenable en débrief d'ailleurs les
chroniqueurs sont tous absolument mais
consterné
voilà c'est la première fois de ma vie
cyril quand plateau j'ai le public qui
hurlent derrière moi que je me retourne
qu'il ya des gens qui pleurent dans le
public non et que le public me prend
dans ses bras en me disant ce que tu
viens de vivre est trop violent
on veut juste partager avec toi voilà
donc je ne suis pas non plus une
hystérique quelle majorité les plombs
sur pété les plombs
la séquence a été extrêmement douloureux
à vivre il ya eu l'instant pub où
personne n'était là où j'ai réglé moore
qui est devant moi et qui me nargue
voilà ça a duré toute l'émission est
encore en partant donc non alors vous
avez tous été ensuite je vous informe
réfléchir a déposé plainte contre
monsieur zemmour sur le plateau vous
dites j'ai subi des insultes graves
ainsi que mes parents très affectée par
la violence de la scène que j'ai eu à
vivre et vous n'avez pas vu ce soir je
réfléchis à quitter l'émission vous avez
dit également il ne gagnera pas cette
fois j'ai tous les éléments en ma
possession
il n'en sortira pas indemne et pour mes
parents et mon identité insulté ce soir
j'irai jusqu'au bout quelles que soient
les conséquences
à bonn en à bon entendeur et c'est vrai
que hapsatou mais vous étiez tout seul
avec lui à ce moment là pendant la pub
il a continué à vous pendant la pub il y
a
une séquence où quelqu'un mais je vais
pas je vais pas revenir sur tous les
détails mais où ils ricanent parce que
je suis mise effectivement en difficulté
donc ce tweet que je mets derrière un il
est réfléchi
voilà je dis qu'effectivement il gagnera
pas cette fois mais le tweet même
précédent où je dis je vécus si on peut
le revoir juste un instant sur voilà
enfin je vais réfléchir à déposer
plainte
c'est simplement pour vous dire que même
la direction de la chaîne en voyant les
images a été tellement choquée et ils me
l'ont dit ils n'ont pas pu diffuser
parce que cela contrevenait à la loi
c'est dur que ce que j'ai subi en
plateau n'était pas légale n'étaient pas
acceptables n'était pas voilà je
mangeais pas grandi et je me suis pas
battu pour être ce que je suis c'est à
dire une femme libre indépendante pour
subir ça je ne l'accepté ou pas et même
pas dans le cadre de mon travail
donc effectivement je vois que monsieur
delormeau et très excité veut revenir
dessus c'est de la soupe mais n'est que
jeunesse que ça fait passer la séquence
est s'est passé je me suis renseigné au
début de coupe de 30 minutes d'émission
qui a duré deux heures pourquoi juste
cette question pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
parti au bout du manageur de l'émission
son camp c'est et ses violentes le souk
de réveiller les aurais tu me l'as que
moi on m'a dit que vous avez été blessé
mais vous restez les deux heures
d'émission vous débattez avec tout le
long et tout ça j'aimerais vous pourquoi
dans mis une heure et demie pour tout
d'un coup est très très très touché par
une séquence qui s'est passé une heure
et demie à vous êtes mal informé
monsieur de leur ment parce qu'on vous
l'avez expliqué on vous expliquerai que
j'ai passé l'émission a pleuré que ça ne
servait pas aux petits montrer qu'elle
sait pas que je suis née motive c'est
qu'à un moment il ya des séquences qui
sont violentes et je suis humaine
effectivement devant la violence j'ai
craqué ce qui est humain le voilà rang
et toute lassitude toute l'émission a
été effectivement extrêmement pénible à
vivre pour moi et je suis resté jusqu'au
bout parce qu'on m'a demandé de rester
voilà je me suis levé après la séquence
j'ai craqué je suis parti me calmer je
suis revenu c'est aussi mon boulot moi
la base je fais du divertissement
je suis pas une polémiste je suis pas je
fais pas des débats politiques de métal
en essayant plateau voilà quand je me
retrouve face et une séquence comme ça
où on agresse je suis pas formés pour ça
je ferme la télé ça veut pas dire tout
subir tout accepter et repartir parce
que c'est que la télé oui c'est que la
télé mais là j'ai été attaqué
personnellement dans mon être donc ça
c'est difficile effectivement à vivre et
à dire ouais vous dites que tu alors que
je suis devenu incontrôlable
vous n'imaginez pas un homme
dans la violence de ce que j'ai vécu je
vous ai vu moi dans cette émission un
peu plus incontrôlable aussi c'est vrai
voilà vous l'avez été nommé sur la forme
sur le contenu je suis le fond je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous totalement
total et si vous connaissez la voyant
leur mari était d'accord aussi sur la
forme et jusque de ce que vous nous
dites de la forme ça me semble
extrêmement violent parce que ce n'est
pas que ça va continuer autant derrière
qui l'avait insulté vos parents et c'est
vrai que c'est extrême orient d'ailleurs
ces 8 n'a pas pu diffuser la séquence
est donc cette histoire
coutinho est ce que vous avez porté
plainte je suis avec mon avocate depuis
jeudi d'accord bat eric zemmour sentir
toujours
donc là il faut faire très attention on
est en train d'analyser la chose et oui
ma volonté absolue à moi c'est de
déposer plainte
la volonté c'est aussi ce que j'ai dit
c'est que eric zemmour ne puisse plus
insulter les enfants de la république
comme ça librement sur des chaînes de
télévision donc effectivement je demande
des excuses à eric zemmour je demande
qu'ils s'excusent aussi auprès de tous
les jeunes qui l'a alors de la
république qu'il a offusqué
j'ai justement de chêne juste d'être
solidaire et cesser de le laisser
débattre oui émettent des opinions avec
lesquels je suis pas d'accord totalement
d'accord c'est le principe du débat
insulter c'est plus le débat et à partir
du moment où ils insultent et
l'insultent une chroniqueuse devant tout
le monde
je suis désolé là il faut que les
chaînes agissent elles ne lèvent pas
impunément faire schio alors d'où vient
ce qui s'est passé vous dites qui vous
aimeriez qui s'excuse mais il est invité
donc le lundi 11h04 eric zemmour il
invitait d'audrey crespo-mara qui est la
femme de thierry ardisson et il ne
s'excuse absolument pas regarder avait
dit absatou ci avec un prénom comme le
vôtre ne fait pas partie de la
république non j'ai pas dit ça on ne
parle on est on est on est pas dans leur
sens parce que c'est pas un prénom n'est
pas dans la france c'est pas un prénom
français
si un prénom du calendrier les saints
chrétiens gsm exactement à gérer quand
même la violence inouïe de dire à
quelqu'un
le prénom vous avec le prénom vous
portez vous ne faites pas partie de moi
on se trouve beaucoup plus violent des
gens qui donnent à leurs enfants parce
que c'est pas elle que j'accuse en
l'occurrence ce sont ses parents qui
donnent à des enfants des prénoms qui
sont étrangers à l'histoire de france
alors qu'eux ils veulent que leurs
enfants vivent en france
pour vivre en france il faut s'assimiler
à l'histoire de france à la culture
française
alors il a il a refusé de s'excuser et
13h52 tir ardisson publie un communiqué
concernant la situation
la séquence de l'émission les terriens
du dimanche du 16 septembre à laquelle
fait référence à toucy a été
délibérément coupé au montage selon les
instructions du service juridique de ces
huit ce que vous nous expliquer ni un
instant comme ça prend quand à absinthe
ou si elle souhaite quitter l'émission
il faut qu elle en informe rapidement
thierry ardisson ou stéphane simon le
producteur est ce que vous avez senti un
manque de soutien de la part de la
production ou est ce que vous comprenez
thierry ardisson qui dit elle à elle a
commencé à dire qu'elle voulait quitter
l'émission moi je me désolidarise de non
je ne comprends pas vraiment non je ne
comprends pas je tiens quand même à
préciser que je suis soutenue par la
chaîne qu'eric zemmour pense être
suffisamment puissant pour parler au nom
de la chaîne et dire que j'ai été bon
gré non je ne suis pas virer je
rencontrais franck appietto gérald brice
viret qui m'ont assuré de leur soutien
un tueur mais des inconditionnels et qui
m'ont même annoncé que je resterai de
toute façon sur l'antenne
quoi qu'il arrive j'étais de la famille
s'est vite et oui effectivement je
voyage je vois le communiqué il est
froid
il est ce qu'il est mais c'est pas grave
on file avait eu au téléphone sur
ardisson non je n'ai pas eu tir est roi
depuis cette histoire vous n'avez pas eu
de tirs a dit son téléphone
non jean marc était quand ils disent
qu'ils vous ont à l'airé des meilleurs
marc alyn week end c'est vrai ou pas
alors ça je voudrais rectifier parce que
je passe pour vraiment la fille
effectivement incontrôlable qui veut par
la personne francs capitaux m'a appelé
toulouse auxerre président lula piétons
ou le président de la chaîne m'appelait
tous week-end j'ai répondu à un premier
appel
et puis ensuite j'ai expliqué franck que
j'avais pas la force de me parler j'y
arrivais pas j'arrivais pas juste voilà
j'ai dit que j'avais pas la force de
parler c'était facile on m'appelait
vendredi pour me dire que la séquence
était coupée parce que je me permets de
dire parce qu'il l'a dit sur votre
plateau nous avons échangé je lui ai dit
mon désaccord mais après je comprends
que ça a été coupée pour des raisons
juridiques et qu'il a fait son travail
il a fait son travail de couper avec la
chaîne parce qu'il n'avait pas le deal
n'avait pas d'autre choix
c'est le montage moi que je condamne
c'est pas le fait d'avoir d'avoir coupé
et de samedi-dimanche je n'ai eu
absolument personne donc vous trouvez
faux de dire qu'on m'appelait tout le
week-end et personne n'arrive à me
joindre
franck m'a appelé je lui ai répondu que
j'étais pas joignent à eux que j'ai déjà
et pas parler c'est tout alors mardi
matin alors là le torchon brûle cette
fois entre thierry ardisson et vous et
c'est tout thierry va indirectement et
il était invité chez jean marc morandini
et il a parlé d'argent vous concernant
et là c'est là que ça s'est envenimée
entre vous et lui rien week-end et elle
n'a pas décroché son téléphone pendant
tout le week-end
elle s'étale sur twitter pour faire un
batteur qui est complètement nul elle
menace aujourd'hui de ne plus revenir
dans l'émission avec les chiens ne
revient pas dans l'émission elle ne
revient pas dans l'émission ce qui
prouve en plus ne pas une volonté c'est
comme l apanage des problèmes d'argent
on lui a avancé signifiant connais pas
beaucoup de productions qui font ces
appareils leur ancien époux alors des
gants non je ne le fais pas ça c on en
rigole mais c'est vrai que la sexy c'est
chaud quand même à ce qui se passe c'est
vrai que là je vous le dis hapsatou de
source sûre thierry regrette un peu ce
qu'il a dit là ouais un peu de regrets
ce qu'il a dit là ce qu'il a dit là
puisque thierry c'est pas un mauvais
bougre mais c'est quelqu'un voilà qui
peut voilà se laisser emporter par ces
un homme de spectacle et je pense que
l'asse laisse un petit peu emporter et
je vous jure qu'ils regrettent ces
paroles cherchent peut dire qu'un
meeting
oui c'est une violation de la vie privée
2 je précise quand même que j'avais un
projet avec stéphane simon avec les six
émissions que l'on était en droit social
pour financer le projet en attendant
qu'on collabos réellement la rentrée et
troisième point moi mon combat il n'est
pas contre thierry ardisson et stéphane
simon
c'est des gens que j'apprécie que
j'apprécie énormément qui m'ont fait
confiance
voilà avec qui j'ai travaillé depuis un
an et que je respecte parce que cyril tu
me connais je travaille pas si je
respecte pas et j'ai été très très
affecté par ce que thierry qu'a été
bienveillant avec moi par le passé là
pour moi se désolidariser à un moment où
j'avais besoin qu'ils soient solidaires
pareil pour stéphane mais mon combat il
est pas contre stéphane il est pas
content retirer c'est encore une fois
ils peuvent avoir l'opinion qu'ils
veulent de moi ils peuvent décider de se
défendre comme il en fait je pense pas
avoir créé tout seul le bad buzz
je pense que les sorties tirer mon
influence est lourdement le blackbird
donc voilà donc s'il m'entende
encore une fois je suis pas contre eux
voilà je suis pas contre eux je chéris
m'a fait bosser pendant un an et je
crache pas dans la soupe allant jusqu'à
moi tout ça tout ça ce qu'il a dit après
ça alors là ça vous a mis dans une furie
puisque vous avez pris la difficile
décision de diffuser sur instagram les
séquences coupées au montage
dans cette séquence que nous ne pouvons
pas diffuser on peut plus à diffuser
pour des questions juridiques
eric zemmour vous dit votre prénom est
une insulte à la france
la france n'est pas une terre vierge
c'est une terre avec une histoire là
vous êtes à la fin d'émission qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement ce que
pouvait raconter à nos téléspectateurs
qui s'est passé parce que ça c'est
extrêmement violent comme ce que je
voudrais dire surtout s'est rappelé à
eric zemmour qu' il ya eu des
tirailleurs sénégalais qui sont morts
pour la france at on fait couler leur
sang pour la france qui portent des
prénoms qui sont mus à ousmane etc
et ces gens là s'il ose dire à ces gens
là dans les yeux que leur prénom est une
insulte à la france je ne comprends plus
il dit aussi qu'on fait pas partie de
l'histoire de la france ont été pré
partie du présent
c'est faux c'est comme le débat qu'il ya
eu autour des joueurs de foot de
l'équipe de france les joueurs de
l'équipe de france sont français et
c'est pénible d'avoir à justifier parce
que quand on ne chante pas la
marseillaise
quand on dit qu'on n'est pas fier de la
république on nous le reproche et quand
on la chante la marseillaise parce qu'on
est fier d'être français parce qu'on a
été à l'école de la république et qu'on
est français et c'est tout c'est comme
ça que n'en déplaise à monsieur zemmour
et bien on nous ramène au fait qu'on ne
l'est pas donc évidemment moi c'est
cette séquence moi me fait sortir de mes
gonds parce que c'est une atteinte à mon
identité
c'est une attente il n'a santa mes
parents je suis senna tente à tout ça et
surtout au début quand il me dit ça je
il est incroyable ce titre parce que je
ne je n'aurais je ne suis pas sûr mais
ce qu'il en soit ce saoudite
apparaissent sur réalise réaliste alors
voilà après vous vous dites tir ardisson
à ce jeu là tu vas perdre je n'aime pas
le mensonge c'est une bombe que je vais
lâcher je n'ai pas peur et donc là
forcément ça s'envenime de quelques tirs
ardisson et son producteur ou s'il
voulait dire quelque chose
oui est ce que vous ne pensez pas absent
tout comme certaines informations le
laisse entendre que zemmour avait
prémédité son attaque elle est tellement
violente tellement frontale il est en
promotion
est ce que vous n'avez pas été la cible
de quelque chose qui était concertée ce
qui serait encore plus grave
je ne sais pas mais jusque je sais c'est
que ces mots jubilent à l'instant
présent
on continue par les juifs ce que je dis
c'est que je continuera par les temps
qui parle
donc soit on le fait taire ça je
continue à parler je vais en agacer pas
mal mais
pas grave ce qui est sûr c'est que
zemmour il aime le clash il aime le
conflit il sait ce qu'il fait et il sait
pourquoi il le fait donc ça veut dire
qu'il manipule un petit peu cette 7ème
cette violence pour créer du buzz autour
de son livre résultat c'est qu'il en
vend beaucoup
alors comme ça tout avant avant qu'on
voit un petit peu l'avenir avec vous est
ce que vous pensez ce que vous avez
envie de dire même à thierry ardisson
aujourd'hui parce que pourrait peut-être
lui par l'histoire par écran interposé
jean-luc vouliez dire quelque chose non
mais moi je comprends tout à fait que
hapsatou sy a été heurté par ça et
qu'elle est super mal vécu maintenant
est ce que vous vous dites pas que
malheureusement vous avez donné une
caisse de résonance à eric zemmour
fabuleuse et il attendait que c'est donc
vous êtes filmé finalement vous jouer
son jeu bien bien malgré vous et surtout
moi je regardais parce que je regardais
en plus j'étais sur twitter et joignez
vous annonciez de votre départ de
éventuel d'eads était rien du dimanche
je me suis dit pourquoi dans ce coup là
si mal vécu on a l'impression que ce que
vous reprochez aussi c'est de pas avoir
été soutenus pendant le tournage
est ce que c'est ce qu'on ressent est ce
que c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pour
ça que après vous êtes aussi vite en
conflit et coproducteur je comprends
tout à fait ce que vous dites mais c'est
un raisonnement tout le monde a ça veut
dire que plus on répond à eric zemmour
et puis il a une caisse de résonance oui
mais plus on lui répond pas et puis les
deux seuls à être lus et puis là la
parle avec son coeur voilà il est le
seul à être entendue hurler je suis fou
et j'ai dit à un moment j'ai entendu un
truc terrible d'un des partisans d'eric
zemmour qui explique qu'en fait je suis
une vendeuse de produits cosmétiques et
qu'en gros
eric zemmour est un intellectuel qui
travaillent nuit et jour sur son bouquin
mais quel mépris social
je veux ça veut dire quoi c'est dire que
sur ce schéma droit de répondre parce
que je fais je vends des produits de
beauté etc et moi il ya une phrase que
j'ai envie de leur dire moi je préfère
des gens qui ne savent pas grand chose
mais qui ont un grand coeur que des gens
intellectuels penseurs secteur au coeur
sec ça je déteste l'idée absurde
aujourd'hui donc il ya l'affairé zemmour
et puis il ya vous il ya votre avenir
il ya vos relations avec thierry
ardisson avec le producteur et avec les
terriens du dimanche est ce que
aujourd'hui vous en voulez attirer
addition au point de ne plus retourner
dans les terriens du dimanche jusqu'au
bout dit vous voyez retourner avec
thierry ardisson est ce que vous êtes
avides et avait été soutenu par les
autres membres de l'équipe au c est ce
que vous avez été soutenu par les autres
chroniqueurs pas partout ce message
étant ce que vous le savez
c'est par tous mais sur plateau
évidemment sur le plateau suite à la
séquence évidemment intestins bionade
raquel garrido qui parle d'une
excommunication de la france cc monia
qui effectivement choqué de natacha
polony qui intervient outré quand tout
le monde est outrée voilà donc ça c'est
absolument sûr j'ai été soutenu par
certains et non par d'autres mais est-ce
qu'ils sont obligés de soutenir non je
sais pas alors est ce que nous avons
envie d'y retourner
aujourd'hui je discute avec la chaîne
d'accord froid drômois ccc un respect
que je dois à la chaîne que de finir des
discuter avec eux avant de prendre ma
disque de ma décision je suis gg de
nouveaux rendez-vous effectivement en
début de semaine avec qui avec tiroir
avec la direction de 2h est alors retiré
redit son quand il veut alors moi je
suis quelqu'un de deux dentiers je leur
dirai la même chose que ce que je vous
dis hapsatou pour la direction de ses
huit que j'ai lu ce matin au téléphone
il n'y a pas de débat
pour la direction de ses 8 il vous aime
beaucoup c'est un grand talent vous avez
grandi sur ses 8000 devrait vous avez
démarré avec laurence ferrari et vous
avez continué à faire des choses avec
nous aujourd'hui il est hors de question
d'arrêter notre collaboration avec vous
ça c'est sûr et certain
maintenant vous est ce que vous avez
envie de retourner chez tir à dix
lorsque vous voyez retourner chez
thierry ardisson après ce qui s'est
passé
ou est ce que vous dites j'ai peut-être
envie de faire d'autres projets sur ces
8 c'est moi comme je les dis à la base
c'est du divertissement
si on faire taper dessus toutes les
semaines non en revanche ce qui est sûr
c'est que ma décision au moment où je
vous parle
elle n'est pas pressée ce soir vous dit
j'attends par respect pour mes patrons
de chaînes de discuter avec eux en début
de semaine pour dire ce qu'il en est a
pas besoin de positionnement de
l'émission parce que vous dites que vous
êtes dans le divertissement
souvent les terrains dimanche comme
chaque semaine on aura un invité
polémique façon sept mercenaires donc
vous êtes au sida comme des polémistes
oui mais en attendant si vous regardez
l'émission j'étais plutôt sur ce qui
était beauté je parle je suis quelqu'un
carnaby ainsi donc je peux te parlais
regza moore il n'y a pas de problème là
dessus je pense que tout le monde peut
parler à eric zemmour en fait mais
semaine nous vous le disions plus haut
plus comment cette semaine en général
n'en voudrait pas toi alors juste
hapsatou on a vu que hier vous avez vu
les patrons de la chaîne n'est pas
content c'est vite est-ce que ils vous
ont dit on vous soutient quitte à aller
contre thierry parce que si thierry
ardisson dit demain je ne
plus d'apps à tous si dans mon émission
ils font quoi les patrons de ces mythes
c'est ça la question
mine de rien parce qu'il faut ce qu'ils
vont aller contre thierry et dire non
aux absa tous y ira dans ton émission et
c'est comme ça et une discute pas
ou bien ils vont dire non à fsa tout bon
bâtir et ne veut plus de toi on peut
plus cadors moi je suis petit j'ai ri
vaut que tu reviennes je n'en sais rien
je n'ai pas eut tiré du tout alors donc
je ne sais pas c'est plus fonctionner
bactéries progressive mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que moi je suis pas non plus
un déchet oui je suis pas quelqu'un
comprend et qu'on reprend comme ça
clairement aujourd'hui je pense être
aussi libre que thierry de décider ou
pas de revenir dans l'émission est
encore une fois le soutien de la chaîne
est incontestable et ils me l'ont dit de
toute façon tu restes avec nous dans la
chaîne tu feras autre chose vitale est
contre tuerie ah mais c'est pas quitte à
aller contre la chaîne condamne ce que
j'ai vécu
d'accord voilà la chaîne nationale la
chaîne me soutient mais si thierry vous
dis je regrette ce qui s'est passé j'ai
peut-être mal géré cette émission j'ai
peut-être mal géré cette situation
j'aimerais que tu reviennes parce que
voilà on y est importante pour moi dans
l'émission et je te promets que ça se
reproduira plus vous y retourner je
prendrai ma décision après avoir vu la
direction de la chaîne d'accord mais la
direction la chaîne veut que vous
restiez oui mais ils veulent aussi
entendre thierry on veut voir aussi ce
qu'il dira dimanche
voilà en tout cas ce qu est ce qu on a
vu par exemple que chérie avec la
décision elle est prise elle avait
beaucoup soutenu chez rim strictement à
l'époque c'est vrai que thierry était à
fond derrière gérald k j'ai l'impression
qu'avec vous s'est - le carnet complet
voilà c'est plus qu'on peut avoir aussi
une chose c'est que j'ai un caractère
fort tiraient aussi je pars pour les
mêmes raisons que je vois là quand je me
clash et que je faisais dans le conflit
jusqu'au bout c'est parce qu'il sait qui
m'a recruté aussi pour ça parce que je
suis quelqu'un d'associé et que je
j'aime pas les demi-mesures et comme je
dis à quelqu'un que je laime je laime à
fond et comme ce n'est pas le cas c'est
pas le cas donc je ne sais pas je les
infos que j'ai joués diop c'est tout
ouais c'est que thierry c'est thierry
c'est une ans un affectif c'est un
nerveux et thiery il se dit aussi
peut-être qu'il a été un peu loin lui de
son côté danse qu'il a balancé qui
regrette un peu qui il aurait peut-être
pu ou voulu que ce agir autrement je
pense que thierry a envie voilà
peut-être que vous retournez avec lui
que ça s'arrange en tout cas entre vous
mais en tout cas il regrette que ça se
soit passé comme ça je vous le dis et
regrette que ce sur un avis qui vous le
dit
vous me le disait est clairement ce que
je pense c'est quelle est la volonté de
thierry et ya les mots il a pris la
parole pour dire des choses qu'ils
n'auraient jamais dû dire j'attends
qu'il prenne éventuellement la parole
pour dire des choses qu'il doit dire
savait qu'on vous a drôlement soutenu si
donc ça prouve aussi je vais à merci non
mais la chaîne aussi s'est vite je vous
le dis on peut être voilà on a beaucoup
thierry ardisson mais là dessus c'est
vrai que j'ai je vois là je pense que
même lui le pensent aussi il aurait pu
un peu plus vous soutenir dans cette
séquence peut-être que moi aussi
j'aurais fait la même erreur que lui
parce que vous êtes dans les haies dans
l'émission vous rendez non mais on ne
s'est pas franchement c'est pas on peut
pas le dire mais en tout cas voilà quand
vous êtes dans une émission peut-être
que vous laissez passer des choses
mais après la situation s'est envenimée
et je pense que voilà thierry aussi
regrette un petit peu je vous le redis
ce qui s'est passé et géraldine très
vite à ça tout seul est juste savoir
pendant les deux heures d'émission de
tournage des missions vous étiez
complètement meurtri bouleversé en
pleurs il a été comment tirer ardisson
avec vous il a été chaleureux
paternalisme bienveillant et vous a pris
dans ses bras
gêné je n'ai pas de commentaire d'accord
ça veut dire non ouais ça veut dire non
ok tu à venir